صفقه محتمله قد ترسم ملامح العلاقه
المستقبليه بين النظام السوري وتركيا
محورها شمال شرق سوريا وضحيتها قصد
الرافده لاي اتفاق بعد ما خذلتها الولايات
المتحده يقول موقع مدن ان الخطه غير
المعلنه يبدو انها ترتكز على اعاده
الاعتبار لنظام الاسد كدوله وهذا يعني
ازاله كل الكيانات التي تعترض طريق اعاده
تلك الصفه اليه فانقرا قد تقدم على كل على
حل للفصائل العسكريه المعروفه او تقدم على
حال الفصائل العسكريه المعروفه باسم الجيش
الوطني او تسليمها للروس لدمجها لجيش
النظام مع وضع ترتيبات خاصه بهيئه تحرير
الشام بعد انجاز المهمه شرق الفرات وشمال
سوريا اولا ويريد الاتراك انتشارا حقيقيا
لقوات النظام على الحدود معها ودافعها
القوات الكرديه بعيدا او حلها على ان
تتسلم قوه الاسد المعابر الحدوديه على
الاقل في مناطق انتشار الجيش الوطني
وسيكون هذا اكثر من كافا للنظام اذا ما
ساعدته الضغوط التركيه على دفع القوات
الامريكيه للانسحاب من شرقي البلاد واعاده
مناطق الشمال والشرق الى نفوذته اما
بالنسبه لاردوغان فهناك قضايا تشغل بالك
فلنتابعها
[موسيقى]
لكن مشاهدينا طبعا كل هذا السيناريو مبني
على فرضيه ابتدائيه وهي استسلام القوات
الكرديه لنظام الاسد وهو امر لم يحدث بعد
ورفضته قصد كما تقول الشرق الاوسط اما
البديل عن هذه المقترحات فسيكون عمليه
بريه خاطئه لكنها لن تكون سهله عموما وقد
تصنع واقعا مغيرا تقول المدن طبعا وضع
الاكراد او وضع الاكراد كاضحيه لسياسات
الولايات المتحده والغرب ليس جديد عليهم
انما الشديد هذه المره ان قصه ساهمت
بوصلهم الى هذه الحال من ضمن اطراف اخرى
فتاريخيه تعرض الاكراد خلال 100 عام لسبعه
خيانات من الحليفه المفترضه والدعمه
الولايات المتحده
في مقال لها ايضا في الشرق الاوسط تقول
انها لن تكون المره الاولى وربما ليست
المره الاخيره التي قد يتعرض فيها الاكراد
لخيانه امريكيه او غربيه في حال لم يكن
الرد على تواغل تركي ضد اهداف كرديه في
سوريا في مستوى توقعاتهم ولعل اول هذه
الخيانات الامريكيه للاكراد كانت بعد
انهيار الامبراطوريه العثمانيه في الحرب
العالميه الاولى حين خصصت معاهده معاهده
معاهده العام 1920 مساحه للاكراد في تركيا
كي يقيموا حكم ذاتيا ثم تراجعت الولايات
المتحده عنها في معاهدات عام
1963 قامت الولايات المتحده بدعم اكراد
العراق ضد النظام عبد العال كريم قاسم عام
1963 ثم تخلت عن دعمهم بمباركه من اداره
الرئيس الامريكي الجديد انا ذاك جلد
ثمانيات وتسعينيات اداره الرئيس رونالد
ريغان التزمت الصمت على استعمال بغداد
اسلحه كيماويه في كردستان العراق وفي عام
2003 بعد الغزو الامريكي للعراق لم يحصل
الاكراد على تاييد امريكيه يدعم انفصالهم
عن العراق وفي عام 2017 اراد الزعيم
الكردي مسعود البرزاني تنظيم استفتاء
لتقرير المصير فعرضت هنا الولايات المتحده
واعلن التحفظها على هذه الخطوه وفي سوريا
تعرض الاكراد لاكثر من طعنا او من امريكا
بعد ما قتلوا له سنوات ضد تنظيم داعش لكن
هم لم يحصلوا على الدعم السياسي لا بل
تلقوا صدمه لعدم اعتراضيهم على ثلاث
عمليات عسكريه ضد مناطق الاكل شمال سوريا
بين عام 2016 2018 و2019